j'accueille rouchon et syco
il a un gros nez des moustaches et des
lunettes il est tout à fait magnifique
c'est un des deux plus grands animateurs
du monde il s'appelle chico d'agneau il
a aussi un gros nez des moustaches des
lunettes j'ai nommé l'autre animateur
magnifique gros show business y est nous
sommes là tous les samedis soir sur
antenne 2 pour vous présenter la plus
grande émission du monde rock n roll
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
alexandre marcellin alias gros show chez
lui dans le 16e arrondissement de paris
[Musique]
et
toujours très actif il prépare la
programmation musicale d'émissions de
télé mais n'en n'oublie pas moins sa
chienne fidèles comme une ombre c'est du
bon du bon jambon
alléger alors après ça
on va aller travailler mes chiens
beaucoup plus important quand même que
le travail est beaucoup plus d'urgence
ma chienne est formidable parce qu'elle
est un peu sourde mais elle adore la
musique elle sans les vibrations et elle
adore le cinéma également étonnamment je
les emmener voir autant en emporte le
vent il n'y a pas très longtemps et elle
n'a pas du tout aimé le film et j'ai été
très surpris parce qu'elle avait adoré
le livre donc voilà brouchaud n'a
décidément pas perdu son humour
légendaire la preuve dans l'émission il
tient une chronique matinale le chien de
mon père pu énormément du derrière quand
il lui arrive de péter
oui et dieu sait que c'est souvent
m
ma vie' du rouleau
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé a aussi
retrouvé son complice ça me choque car
alias chico lors de sa tournée matinale
des commerçants du 7e arrondissement de
paris pour aller chercher son pain ils
bénéficient d'un accès privé à la
boulangerie melo c'est sam
et bonjour la lutte ça va bien
tu as un beau petit campagne jakubiak eu
tort comme thème voilà là c'est parfait
je connaissais sa voix je connais c'est
un petit peu sa gueule attends je
connais son caractère
bon je ne brûle pas je te remercie
envoyé à très bientôt
allez vous emmène ses journées chico les
consacre à sa fille et à ses proches
mais lui qui est resté un grand enfant
ne manque jamais une occasion de jouer
au pied voilà je tiens juste à dire que
c'est marc qui a fait ça de ces petites
mains tout le décor tout ça et je trouve
ça assez extraordinaire alors voilà
quand on appuie
droite ce qui fait au niveau de
l'échelle
régulièrement une ba voila mais c'est le
plaisir c'est vraiment du plaisir
vraiment un jeu d'enfant réalisé par une
vente personnes-là
gros show aussi aiment passer du temps
avec ses amis son hobby c'est la
pétanque aussi bon
c'est leur hockey j'arrive
tu es là servant pour les cafés est-ce
que tu as les boules ben évidemment une
fois partie s'arrête en bas de la maison
on joue alors normalement on est plus
nombreux aujourd'hui on est deux donc
c'est quand même des moments très très
important si tu veux venir avec moi
qu'il est gentil mais ils trichent
dietrich non c'est trop court
c'est essayer de t'entraîner tu vas
arrêter de te libérer tombera
ah voilà c'est bien la poubelle bush
s'était senti obligé de jouer à gauche
moi tu en voilà regarde aia
et là y'a rien à faire là
pendant ce temps là chico se rend chez
le coiffeur le même depuis vingt ans et
la même coupe très original donc 72,7
coup
j'ai essayé pourtant délaissé poussé
pour les avoir comme toi mais bon c'est
pas évident tu vois et tu t'en la spa
banon tu sais pourquoi en fait j'ai
compris pourquoi ouais parce qu'elle
change avec la couleur de mes cheveux
qui blanchissent conflent mesure au fur
et à mesure c'est l'effet différents
ah ouais c'est vachement bien public
journée les lunettes c'est pas en fin de
journée le duo se reforme pour quelques
heures enfin si tout va bien arriver
enfin j'attends gros comme d'hab ça fait
20 ans que j'attends sur la bourre des
années des années je vais toujours
attendu à la radio la télé à la bourre
voilà voilà non mais tu as vu leur
marché qui a vu leurs
voitures pour
aller d'un coup toujours complices les
deux systèmes se retrouver autour d'un
verre
car retrouver l'internet respectueux des
jouets on est d'une sobriété absolue
ouais mais c'est leur fils et leur qui
fait ça l'un pialat avec l'âge avec
l'âge on renverse
à l'époque à 40 ans ont renversé mois
avec l'âge aujourd'hui on renverse que
je voulais jouer
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
groucho et shiko shiko
shiko bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde à part et ça les jours alors on
va commencer avec vous shiko shiko
d'agneau oui vous êtes bien sous le nom
de sam chouikha oui le 24 septembre 1947
au caire c'est exact air grossistes en
matériel de petite papeterie les crayons
les gommes et bim et mère femme au foyer
absolument alors très jeune vous
découvrez la musique en écoutant la
radio et en 1955 quand vous entendez les
premiers rock vous voulez immédiatement
une guitare que j'ai eue alors dans la
famille on parle français vous
fréquentez le lycée français du caire
mais on parle également arabe anglais et
ladino oui en ladino c'est une langue
judéo espagnol est utilisé notamment en
turquie exactement vous savez encore
parler de l'avion si l'open aux cimes
problème à à oui c'est un peu comme
l'espagnol quand même c'est de
l'espagnol c'est de respecter les niches
espagnole
alors connaissance des langues sera
utile à tous quand après l'arrivée au
pouvoir de nasser vous déciderez de
quitter l'egypte et en 1957 les dix ans
vos parents renoncent à nationalité
égyptienne et de pouvoir partir en
france et là vous arrivez vous êtes
apatrides
petite carte
deux séjours sur laquelle je découvre
que je n'ai pas de nationalité remarquez
nationalité sans
avoir votre père réussit à trouver une
place de grossistes en matériel de
bureau oui il finira par acheter la
boîte quand exact absolument ben c'était
son métier déjà à l'egypte donc le
refaire ici pour lui je pense que ça a
été plus facile alors à l'époque
évidemment vos parents n'ont pas
d'argent au départ ils sont obligés de
vivre à l'hôtel et votre frère et vous
vous êtes inscrit dans une pension juive
et c'est un déchirement parce
qu'évidemment on s'est séparés jamais
quitté les parents de notre vie d'un
seul coup du jour au lendemain on les
voit plus que deux fois par mois ensuite
la famille s'installe à boulogne
billancourt vous passez votre enfant
sans là évidemment on est loin des bords
du nil via les bords de seine
alors heureusement s'inquiéter la
famille part en vacances à nice oui et
c'est là qu'avec votre argent de poche
vous achetez chez ben qui est devenu un
artiste mondialement connue évidemment
vous achetez vos premiers disques
exactement rue ton duty de l'escarène
exactement alors à la même époque à
l'olympia vous voyez les shadows oui
avec la fameuse chanson attaches
absolument voilà vous faites un groupe
jouer dans l'est dans les rallyes dans
l'est sur les brumes la pression après
le bac vous faites lesca quitte une
école de commerce que l'âge de 20 ans et
là bon vous en avais un peu marre de du
côté strict de la vie les études c'est
ça va ça va 5 minutes puis moi j'avais
la musique en tête mon père avait le
commerçant témoin ça ne collait pas
vraiment fissiles alors c'est arlette
tabarre oui fameuse babar l'assistante
de lucien morisse directeur artistique
d'europe numéro un qui vous remarque un
jour où vous accompagner un copain pour
une audition aux disques az exactement
et vous aussi vous passer une audition
par la même occasion c'est à dire que
j'étais sur place je me suis dans le
fond je trouve que c'était bizarre ces
auditions qu'il y avait des jeunes qui
ressemble à claude françois qui venait
chanter du club françois des jeunes qui
ressemble à mireille mathieu qui
chantait du mireille mathieu le copain
de sa compagne et lui bon il avait ses
propres chansons puis moi je déconnais
j'adorerais chanter en anglais et ses
éditions dans le fond est ce que puisque
je suis là ce que je peux passer
l'audition
alors un jour elle vous rappelle et elle
vous demande de présenter le zico rama
spécial jimi hendrix en direct à
l'olympia oui en lire + consensus et
quand même arrêt de tabarre ah bah oui
cc c'est d'abord un c'est une femme qui
est très impressionnante et elle m'avait
dit toi tu as un potentiel qui aiment le
rock tu va présenter hendrix l olympia
je me suis retrouvé en octobre 67 à le
faire alors dans la salle il y avait
votre père votre grand-mère en fait mais
ça ça c'est un souvenir je peux me
vanter de dire que je suis le seul au
monde à avoir vu son père né en égypte
ma mère n'ayant ni de ma grand mère née
en turquie à istanbul qui venaient voir
non pas par ici oui parce que jimi
hendrix à des les affoler ah ben moi je
ne comprenais pas parce que dans la
scène c'était velvetine satine et
passent mal chez l'homme et de moi que
je voyais mon père si je peux me
permettre après le spectacle mon père
est venu me voir
et m'a vraiment posé la question il dit
je voudrais te demander quelque chose
toi tu as été formidable mais ce garçon
et gagne vraiment de la jupe en jouant
de la guitare comme avec son sort
réservé à diouf voilà une impression
alors là le problème c'est que vous ne
rappelait pas babar arrête ta barre et
là votre père vous pousse à entrer chez
olivetti oui ouais c'est un peu plus dur
vous retrouvez à vendre des machines à
écrire des machines à calculer et oui
pour la plus grande satisfaction mon
père le plus beau métier du monde
représentant oui et là vous en
échapperez pour travailler dans
l'industrie phonographique aurait fait
plein de trucs en fait cet auteur
compositeur attaché de presse directeurs
de maisons de dix chanteurs 10 appels
alors ça va exact par sam chez az
évidemment directeur artistique enfin
voilà et vous décidez de quitter le show
biz après tout ça je décide d'arrêter
parce que ça fait très longtemps
beaucoup d'années c'est un métier qui
est très difficile très stressant
contrairement à ce que les gens veulent
croire la gaillette ça s'entretient et
j'en ai marre donc je décide d'arrêter
et là vous faites de la pub des voix
dans la pub alors tout va bien et c'est
là que vous retombez sur alexandre que
vous aviez connu dix ans auparavant ah
oui tout à fait je sors d'un studio pub
comme on disait à l'époque à europe 1
et qui je rencontre cet énergumène qui
lui même était alors pas gros show
business voilà alias alexandre marcellin
quand vous êtes né le 12 novembre 1951 à
paris 9ème vos parents travaillent dans
l'immobilier est petit commerçant
d'abord oui et il faut que le che mat ça
marche plus il passe à l'immobilier
parce qu'il n'y a pas de stock
et oui alors vous passez votre enfance
entre paris et deauville oui parce que
ma grand-mère une boutique à deauville
donc je vais voir mme lam et mai à
deauville tous les week-ends et les
grandes vacances alors votre souvenir
d'enfance le plus marquant c'est le
premier thé pas à l'âge de 7 ans quoi
ouais alors pas par hasard ce que
j'avais été malade j'avais été un nom
couché et mathis particulaire et j'ai
découvert à cette époque la radio et on
m'a offert mon premier thé pas et j'ai
commencé à acheter des disques et je
suis tombé raide dingue de sa
rock'n'roll rock'n'roll et le twist et
la variété et celle avec claude françois
et tout ce qui va avec car à partir de
là pendant vos études au lycée condorcet
de passionnés de musique de radio enfin
vous êtes quoi en fait globalement je
pense qu'à ça globalement je pense qu'à
ça je suis un élève excessivement moyens
et avec les potes on n'a qu'une idée en
tête c'est lé à la gare saint lazare au
magasin le discobole pour écouter ou
s'ils auraient les champs elysées tce
symphonia bien sûr pour parler
véritablement écouter les nouveautés
parce qu'elle passait par la radio allez
acheter les imports tout l'argent de
poche passe là-dedans passion absolue et
partagent avec les potes tiens tu
connais ça tiens tu connais ça on
échange ça on écoute sa passion complète
et alors les études passent très très
loin derrière alors à l'époque voulait
pas devenir animateur en fait vous êtes
programmateur et réalisateur animateur
jamais c'est arrivé tard par accident
moi mon truc c'est de rentrer dans une
radio europe 1 clairement et pour faire
quoi je sais pas je le dis pour choisir
les disques c'était un monstre je savais
pas que ça s'appelait programmateur et
c'est en 1971 que pierre delanoë qui est
alors le patron d'europe 1 vous découvre
alors que vous faites le dj nadeau oui
parce que quand j'avais 18 ans
j'arrivais que avec tous les potes et on
a eu en boîte et on trouvait le disque
est absolument à chier de l'époque chez
régine on a été voir je sais plus qui le
directeur du casino à l'époque on lui
disant votre disquaire il est vraiment à
chier le mec mais vous pourriez faire
mieux dit bien sûr très prétentieux et
je suis arrivé le week-end suivant avec
mes valeurs de disques et pendant je
crois une saison d'hiver et d'été aux
brumes elle est ensuite dans une autre
boîte aux galápagos j'ai fait ce qu'on
appelait disquaires jusqu à ce qu était
formidable parce que d'abord on passait
la musique on voulait pour faire tomber
les gonzesses c'était quand même un très
très grand bonheur et on était les rois
du monde bien soirée un mec qui vient me
voir je faisais des études à l'époque
dentaires ce qui m'intéressait pas un
quart de seconde et ce type me dit c'est
vachement bien ce que vous passiez et il
me dit c'est étonnant vous voulez faire
quoi dans la vie vous fait que je lui
dit en rigolant je dis moi je rêve de
faire de la radio je rêve de rentrer
europe 1 je sais pas qui c'était et le
mec me dis bah écoutez je vous laisse ma
carte et c'est moi le téléphone voilà je
m'appelle piano et je suis directeur des
programmes d'europe 1 huit jours après
il a téléphoné chez moi mes parents et
je suis rentré leur pain en 71 19 ans
conte de fées total alors après un stage
de programmation avec babar et un
laitage de réalisation sur campus une
émission de michel lancelot je me suis
mis à travailler avec les gens qui
étaient complètement mes idoles courait
avec lancelot et pai a eu bien eu un
paquet parce que pendant dix ans vous
allez réaliser dans la mission chez
europe 1 et jean loup la faune y en a
vanté musique avec jardin zoologique il
ya eu christian morin gildas jouffa
pierre pêcheurs voilà coluche du monde
ensuite vous fondez radio bleue ça c'est
la première radio c'est en 80 à la
demande de jacqueline baudrier ça a été
la première radio seniors ensuite radio
capitale la radio de perdriel pierre
d'une nouvelle 80
80 une date importante puisqu'il ya un
monopole de la radio qui tombe et là il
pas au lit on monte notre première radio
fm un voilà et c'est à ce moment là que
vont retomber voilà sur sam hanna rivaux
et voilà l'heure je saurai au pub on y
arrive mais voilà et alors je montre
cette radio et je suis un mec sérieux je
suis un mec patron de radio avec la
cravate et autres et je cherche des
animateurs et je me souviens d'une
espèce de dario moreno que j'avais connu
dans les années 70 qui arrivait de chez
barclays avec des disques sous les bras
on était devenus très très potes tous
les deux on aller bouffer dans les
restaurants casher et yiddish tous les
deux mariés à se raconter des bêtises et
à se partager à la même musique on est
des malades mentaux de musique et je
choisis ce mec là il est drôle c'est mon
copain il connaît la musique ça va faire
un formidable animateur de radio je
l'appelle je lui fais passer un casting
à toi et à laurent boyer
catastrophe et 2 le truc c'est que moi
habitués à travailler avec les états
unis ont fait beaucoup de voyages aux
états unis à l'époque pour moi la ffmc
représentait un bon jour avec une grosse
voix on est sur l'autoroute et c est
limité à chier j'ai dit
que je les engage pas ni l'un ni l'autre
la différence c'est que tous les deux
vous continuez à vous voir quand même
sur et en dehors du boulot dix ans et
quand vous quittez capital pour créer 95
2 avec robert namias là vous faites une
émission tous les deux en fait il n'ya
pas de pognon dimanche c'est pas quoi
faire accident de parcours voilà une
animatrice qui prend des vacances
personne a remplacé namias me dit tu te
démerdes on n'a plus de budget j'appelle
sam et je lui dit écoute j'ai jamais
parlé moi dans un micro de ma vie c'est
pas mon truc toi non plus mais on va
faire comme à la maison c'est à dire tu
vas venir écouter dit je vais prendre
les miens et puis on va servir tu te
souviens de sa écoute ça écoute ça et je
vais dit jia juste un truc on risque
d'être tellement mauvais moi je suis un
mec un peu connue maintenant dans ce
métier un peu sérieux et tout je veux
pas faire ça sous mon nom on va prendre
des surnoms et voilà comme il ressemble
à groucho oui gros show business voilà
moi vu mon physique j'ai dit chico le
contraire et d'agneau des newell et là
vous faites le légendaire montparnasse
graffiti quoique et et moi je me
souviens à l'époque
non absolument culte la gloire ça sera
la télé avec le top 50 et rock'n'roll
graffiti en ouverture des enfants du
rock oui absolument et ça ça a été pour
nous quelque chose de totalement
inattendu c'est que on tourne les les
émissions des requins de graffitis on
les tourne au mois de juin moi je pars
en vacances je vais en grèce 15 juillet
je suis sur le port je prends mon petit
café ma chemise hawaïenne je suis
tranquille etc et je vois les touristes
qui arrivent et qui n'arrête pas de me
regarder et moi je ne comprenais juste
pas ce qui se passait c'est comme ça que
j'ai compris que l'émission avait
cartonné ouais en fait et c'est vraiment
en voyant les gens c'est comme ça vous
arrive c'est alors qu'elle a été la
réaction de votre entourage votre père
par exemple à ce moment là à mon père
lui pour lui ça a été fin d'un seul coup
il avait oublié son commerce avait
oublié qu'il fallait que je rentre dans
son commerce et des rats mais tu
formidable vraiment je t'adore quand je
te vois à la télé c est la télé associe
deux parties ces voiliers parler comme
ça avec s'enrichir c'est quand on disait
qu'il avait l'accent de dalida y trouver
qu'il n'avait pas l'air
et en fait la télévision je tiens
aujourd'hui à lui à lui rendre vraiment
grâce parce que c'est vrai que on oublie
tout simplement que nos parents nous
regardent et donc on est avec eux
finalement je lui tenais compagnie et
voilà je ne saurai jamais trop remercier
terrain il était ravi ravi ma part en
moi pareil alors nous on a le même
parcours moi je suis petit-fils
d'ashkenazi arrivée de l'immigration
pologne début du siècle quand un jour
ils m'ont vu à la télévision faire le
clown parce qu'on vivrait on faisait
vraiment clown il aurait pu trouver ça
ridicule un visa d'or et ça ils étaient
de fierté absolue dites moi à l'époque
the young d'argent et tout ça non non
c'était pas gagné leur vie oui on va
dire ça comme ça mais on a gagné notre
vie parce qu'à l'époque n'avait pas les
producteurs indépendants on était là on
était vachement bien payés parce qu'il
faisait de la radio plus de là
plus de la télé plus un peu de pub plus
des dessins ont gagné très bien notre
vie de l'argent non non l'élégant 16 on
était vachement sérieux et oui moi je
j'ai épousé mon animatrice à l'époque à
rien j'ai engagé cricri à 95,2 ouais
épouse et donc moi je bouge pas une
oreille oui je sais pas t'imagines
aurait-il bouger une oreille maintenant
je pouvais pas bouger les domaines et
espère aujourd'hui une chose c'est que
je suis un fidèle un mâle ans avant tout
fidèle à main c'est vrai c'est jamais vu
bouger une oreille et n'a jamais fait
bouger une oreille non mais toi j'ai
connu beaucoup de choses ouais mais
c'est un petit matin dit tu as connu
tout mais marié injuste oui mais oui
mesdames la première erreur de jeunesse
la deuxième erreur tout court est la
troisième la bord du lac
quel a été le meilleur moment de toute
cette époque
le moment le plus magique quoi
alors moi très honnêtement c'est la
naissance de 95 2 way puisqu'on a eu
avec namias la chance d'avoir à partir
de 80 2 les moyens de nos ambitions à
savoir il fallait pas le dire à l'époque
mais c'était europe 1 qui nous finance
est en sous marin on avait des studios
somptueux et on avait surtout la
possibilité de payer nos animateurs donc
on a réuni autour de nos une dream team
incroyable de gens qui aujourd'hui
n'existe dans cette profession qui sont
laurent boyer qui est il n'a guy thierry
beccaro et là de retrouver mon pote pour
ses émissions qu'on faisait qui était
rock'n'roll graffiti moi c'était ma
récré parce que j'étais en fait patron
de la radio et tout d'un coup je mettais
ma casquette elle gus et j'allais faire
le con avec lui à l'antenne et vous
savez c'était quoi elle ne monte plus
magique de l'époque je crois que c'est
vraiment le premier soir quand on aller
au resto et qu'on entendait des gens dit
on a été écouté les deux cons
et là moi ça m'a recycle a été très
agréablement le pire moment de cette
époque alexandre la mort michel lancelot
puisque en 80 quand on l'a monté 95,2
etc namias on a en a réengagé michel
lancelot qui était plus du tout du tout
dans l'actualité et c'est quelqu'un qui
pour nous avait vachement content et on
était persuadé qu'il avait encore des
trucs à dire depuis un an après un soir
on m'a passé un petit coup de téléphone
on m'a dit voilà michel vient de mourir
il était au parc des princes il a
engueulé larbitre sur un match de foot
il a eu une crise cardiaque ça ça a été
un truc très dur et le lendemain matin
c'était un samedi bon bah on a fait
notre émission en direct qui a été une
émission en hommage à michel et ça a été
un bon moment mais abonnement voilà le
propos durant un brin firme heymans
était celui là oui by alors en 1991
alexandre décidé d aviva serre chevalier
et c'est la fin du duo qu'est ce qui
vous a pris j'en ai marre 1 j'en avais
marre et je n'avais pas envie à cette
époque-là de devenir un animateur de
télévision un peu ringard qui cherchent
du travail nous marie france brière nous
avait viré de la télé un an avant on
l'avait quand même mal pris et je si
j'ai plus envie de tout ça j'ai plus
envie et j'ai envie de vivre autre chose
autrement ailleurs avec ma petite femme
on est partis effectivement on s'est
pris une année sabbatique qui a duré dix
ans à serre-chevalier il voulait partir
de voulait partir et quand est ce qu'on
peut faire on peut rien faire mais moi
je me suis retrouvée à la fois divorcée
orphelins moins quelques points voilà
c'est un peu le problème est nostalgique
aujourd'hui de l'époque non
nostalgie des souvenirs formidables 094
j attends que d'être est de très bon
goût nostalgie moi je sais pas ce que
c'est alors ça mais si c'était à refaire
votre vie qu'est ce que vous me referiez
pas pareil bon je vais leur dire ce ne
serait pas vraiment une erreur c'est je
ne dirais pas mes parents que je
présente jimi hendrix à l'olympia pour
ne pas les voir arriver parce que ça m'a
foutu leur traque de m
et vous l'erreur la vraie il y en a une
qui est très très très grave je peux
l'avouer maintenant
quand on voit les photos on se rend
compte c'est la barbe entre 18 et 24 ans
j'ai eu le barbe maxime le forestier
avec les cheveux john lennon et les
petites lunettes alors j'ai raser ma
barbe compte sur lennon a rasé la sienne
évidemment et j'ai gardé la moustache
mais clairement si il y avait un truc à
faire ou à ne pas faire surtout c'est la
barbe si on voit les photos c'est pour
quand vous allez mourir que je voulais
qu'on remarque sur leurs tombes
tant va la cruche à l'eau qui est à
l'appareil
alors moi j'aurais pas de tombe moi
j'aurais pas de tombe il faudra
disperser les cendres à deauville à là
où je vais à la pêche c'est à dire tout
au bout de l'acheter voilà il faudra
disperser les cendres là il y aura rien
de marquer et si quelqu'un veut me faire
une petite visite ça sera là bas les
gars vous avez fait très heureuse
merci merci les pointures de ne rien
rater le in auditive abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu